99 was a good year got Will Smith a
forest pump I got to do I can't
recognize who's that see no knows the
name see it's over
cover cover those they should just made
it those who because I just question my
whole stance on it don't do that - we'll
look that's a forest Tom Cruise in the
amber car being a fish polo inside the
magazine is really that just embodies
what GQ is as a bread it's just so
well-rounded as you know the highs and
the lows and the Tom Cruise is
definitely higher in AFRICOM knees for
me low 99-mile is your mother doing such
a scumbag I love him
Michaels runner Donald Trump is the same
kind of person Michael Jordan Donald
Trump they are the epitome of bad people
in America becoming successful see when
I see an image of ja Rule next to a
burning car it just signifies with 50
cent into one of my favorite rappers and
it just hurts my heart
Pat Riley is not the most stylish man
he's so trash but cigarette is tasteful
of us poison the youth true detective
let's just keep cancer alive and to me
that's that embodies him as a person
shoutout afro Kobe man of course it like
his won't make the playoffs but we're
talking Kobe has a specific person he'll
be great Michael Phelps need let us all
down I just want get his ass whupped not
too long ago like a couple years back
couldn't put the cash down man I rock
with Lenny Mehra I know about the
nibbler his oh it's kind of quiet for
all that happy Kanye he was many-year
still kind of his you know he's running
for president - got a little Cayenne man
he's greatest okay for one what is Chris
Paul wearing - what is Chris Paul
wearing for three he makes too much
money to have that watch on before
that's a big-ass tie for five that's a
Jill Scott head
okay okay this is special that's
probably top 2 GQ covers of all time why
is Chris Rock on Empire I kind of
stopped destroying the black community
with stuff like that well since you
bring crack back
I'm prefer crack bring crack back at
least at least you could be a crackhead
at least that has a negative connotation
people this Empire stage is going way to
over